but there was another scenario
pointed out to me by somebody who knows
the 49ers quite well
trade the 43rd pick in the draft
to the jets and get sam darnold okay
and don't trade jimmy garoppolo
basically keep garoppolo around
and know that in essence the hot breath
of sam darnold is coming down his neck
and this is the year that will decide if
you're the long-term quarterback
of the san francisco 49ers or
if we move to darnold or someone else
because mike
everybody has always said well you know
if you get darnold you've got a you know
you've got to guarantee that fifth year
and all that no you don't
you know
that can be
sam darnold is smart enough to know that
if they move away next year
from jimmy garoppolo he's smart enough
to know
i've died and gone to heaven if i could
work with kyle shanahan on a contending
team every year
and so
are you going to take the last dime in a
contract if you become a free agent not
saying you would maybe in december of
this year they'd go after him hard and
try to sign him but but anyway i'm
getting ahead of myself i'm just simply
saying that i do not think that trading
for sam darnold would automatically mean
end of days for jimmy garoppolo in san
francisco
here's the only problem with that
scenario
when as a practical matter
the cap is dropping
25 million
from where it was supposed to be it's
one thing to focus on the reduction of
15.7 but it had gone up by 10 million
every year since 2013 teams were
expecting another 10 million bump 208 is
what they were expecting it's 182.5
instead when you take a 25 million
dollar difference and throw on top of it
garoppolo making 25 million this year
that's too much to pay garoppolo if
they're gonna do that they need to
squeeze garoppolo to take less and
that's why last week i was intrigued by
the report that the 49ers had called the
panthers about teddy bridgewater because
bridgewater is due to make 17 million
this year and i thought maybe that was a
way
to subtly open the door to the reality
that the 49ers aren't going to pay
garoppolo 25 million this year because
let's face it peter if they would cut
him no one's paying him 25 million this
year not not for a guy that's missed 23
games more than he's won
over the past four years
over the last three years um and mike
the other way to look at that story
is just simply to say that
you know because my belief is that kyle
shanahan still really likes garoppolo
but
the the
you know the realistic
part of this story
is that if he slips on a banana peel on
october 1st and he's out for the year
they can't rely on cj the cj beathards
of the world you know nick mullins you
can't rely on them anymore because they
have shown they're nice backup
quarterbacks nice but they're not
winning elements
on a you know on a playoff team
and like when the eagles had nick foles
they knew that they could win playoff
games with nick foles now he's not the
greatest quarterback in the world but
they knew that he was good enough to win
playoff games
and in san francisco
that's one of the reasons why i would go
out and get on his rookie contract one
more year of sam darnold and i would say
hey listen i can't tell what's going to
happen at the end of this year i really
can't but for now
having a garoppolo darnold combo platter
in a football sense not in a salary cap
sense but in a football sense really
makes you a better team
there's one wild card in san francisco
and i'm not suggesting that he's going
to get the job or he's going to do
enough to even stay on the roster but
they have josh rosen remember he was
content last year to be on the tampa bay
practice squad and then the opportunity
arose to go to san francisco and he
jumped at the chance to work with kyle
shanahan and in that system there's a
chance there's a chance they develop the
right relationship the right chemistry
and if rosen is smart enough to know
that the path to success in shanahan's
offense is to do exactly what shanahan
wants
every way every play every read every
step every throw if he can figure that
out and do it consistently he's got a
chance
to be the guy and that would be the
steal of all steals a top 10 quarterback
from 2018 that you get on the street and
you quietly groom behind the scenes into
a quarterback that can be the answer for
you over the long haul long way to go
before that happens but it just shows
you that shanahan has options he knows
how to work with quarterbacks and uh
bottom line is they're not ready to pull
the plug on garoppolo so the patriots
not
able to wait for garoppolo pivot to cam
newton he will be back with new england
according to now multiple reports newton
back to the patriots on a one-year deal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports